vision really matters right like when
you have far off destination that you're
pursuing you have you can adapt much
more easily
so let's let's take a a silly analogy
let's say you live
on the east coast and you want to go to
the west coast
you pick a route you pick a highway you
pick a
a road and you make your way towards
where you're you're going
um now all of a sudden there's a car
accident and there's a blockage
and everything comes to a grinding halt
you have options
you can either sit in the traffic or you
can take the first exit
and take a slower more meandering road
but you're still going in the basic same
direction
companies with vision that's like having
a destination
they are able to pivot go sideways go
around go
slower go on small roads but they have a
basic sense that they're moving in the
same
and right direction companies without
vision companies without a sense of the
infinite
uh road ahead um uh they're gonna sit
there and panic
we're not moving we're not going and if
they do take a side road they'll have no
idea which one to take or which
direction to go in
um and so that infinite mindset sets
these
long distance just causes that help
focus us and give us a direction
especially when we face blockages